-Our next guest is the wife of
the late Senator John McCain
and the chair of the board
of the McCain Institute,
where she leads the Human
Trafficking Advisory Council
Please welcome to the show
Cindy McCain.
How are you, Cindy?
-Thank you.
I'm well.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-It's always lovely to see you
And I want to talk about
the fact
that you are
a lifelong Republican
who has endorsed Joe Biden
I did not realize, however, that
Dr. Jill Biden introduced yo
and your late husband,
Senator John McCain.
-Yes, she did.
It was fun.
It was in Hawaii.
I was invited with my parent
to a reception
that was being held
for a group of senators
on their way
through Hawaii to China,
and John happened to be there.
And although I didn't see this
when it initially happened
but I guess when I came in
the room, he was staring at me
And she said, "Go meet her
Go over there and talk to her.
So he did.
And the rest is history.
-Was his --
Did he have a good approach game
when he first came over?
Were you interested immediately?
-Yeah.
No, I was.
I mean, you know --
when he walked over to me, I -
"Ooh, this guy's really cute."
And later on that night,
we went and had a drink
at the Royal Hawaiian Hotel,
which is --
you know, it has tiki --
tiki torches
and everything else going on
And then he called me
from China.
He wound up calling me
from China when he got there
So it was -- I guess it was love
at first sight.
It was fun.
-Can you talk a little
about the transition you mad
from, one, sort of privately
supporting Joe Biden
to making the decision
to go public with it?
-Mm-hmm.
Well, you know, it was
gradual in some respects.
You know, I, like everyone else,
had watched
what was going on
with this president and with -
and the actions
that the White House
were taking on various issues.
And, you know, it started --
like everyone,
I spent my day yelling at the TV
when I was watching it.
And the final blow for me,
not only just the lack
of empathy and compassion,
the lack of character,
the absolute unbelievable issu
of not working in
a bipartisan fashion at all,
but the final blow for me
was when he called
our troops losers and suckers.
And I have three members
of my family, two sons
and a daughter-in-law,
that are serving.
And I -- at that point I said,
"I can sit here
and yell at the TV,
or I can get up
and do something."
And so that's what I did, and
decided to openly endorse him.
I am a Republican, though,
and I am going
to remain a Republican.
-So I wonder what you would sa
to other Republicans
whose intention
is to, obviously,
stay loyal to the party,
who are making this decision
between maybe not supporting
the President,
but also being hesitant
to vote for Joe Biden.
Maybe a lot of them would say,
"Well, I'm just not
going to vote at all."
What would you say to them
-Well, that's what I'm tryin
to help avoid, obviously.
Judging by the outcome of all --
Now what? 67 million early
ballots have been turned in.
I think we're not going to
have a problem
with people not voting.
But what I do want people
to realize, look, this is --
you know, I don't agree
with Joe on everything.
I believe that Joe will work
in a bipartisan fashion, though,
to reach common ground
and work on issues
that are important for us.
And more importantly, I mean
a large part of this is the fact
that Joe has a COVID plan.
Unlike the White House
and the rest of the members,
he believes it's real.
He believes and talks
to the scientists involved
And now, you know,
it's time that we put
his plan into action.
It's things like that
that I tell Republicans
when they ask me.
You know, it's --
I'm tired of some --
of my president
not having my back on things
And more importantly,
not having our country's
back internationally.
You know, we've left
our allies behind.
We've left our --
We've withdrawn
from treaties, et cetera.
I mean, our country is not wel
respected overseas
either in all of this.
There's a lot at stake here.
-Your husband was attacked
by the President
in his trademark
style of cruelty,
not only when he was alive
but after he passed.
Do you think John would
enjoy the fact
that he's still taking up
so much head space
of the President?
-Our family's talked
about that a little bit.
I know one thing for sure.
John would be very disappointe
in what's going on right now
This is not -- This was not,
you know, what he believed in,
nor would he ever have
wanted to ever happen.
I think the fact that he i
taking up head space, though
is kind of hilarious
on occasion.
-You mentioned the lack of
the sort of COVID response plan.
And I think that maybe
runs parallel
with Senator McCain's decision
to give the thumbs-down
to the Obamacare repeal.
It wasn't that he was
a great fan of Obamacare,
but he recognized
in the moment
that there was not
a replacement.
Did you talk to him a great deal
about that moment
when he, you know,
now quite significantly,
broke with his party?
-Right.
We talked about it beforehand.
And, you know --
things like that, I --
To give you a little
behind-the-scenes thing,
a lot was going on
in the cloakroom behind.
The Vice President
was back there.
The governor of Arizona,
I believe, was on the phone.
They were lobbying
my husband pretty hard.
But the one thing he knew
is that we could not do away
with Obamacare without a pla
on the other side
and there was no plan.
So he had, in his mind,
and I believe rightly,
as he agreed,
it was the right thing to do
These kinds of votes
and decisions,
you know, you don't always -
you're not always popular
when you make the right decision
and John knew that,
and John abided by it.
And I'm glad he did
what he did. I really am.
But they did put a full-cour
press on him.
-Obviously right now in th
last week with the campaign,
you've been through this -
-Crazy time right now.
Last week of the campaign
is nuts.
-What is the energy like?
-Oh, it's wild.
No one gets any sleep.
Everyone's really
running on coffee
and probably
a little liquor, too.
And it's just, you know,
it's nonstop.
These last seven days
are nonstop
because you've got to get
to the finish line.
-We crossed paths during
the last seven days in 2008.
-We did.
-For all your accomplishments,
you're also a very
accomplished sketch actor.
-[ Laughs ]
-Here you are.
This was a QVC sketch we did
where, in the final days
of the campaign,
the Senator was trying
to raise some campaign funds
And you did a very good jo
in the sketch.
Do you have fond memories
of that night?
-I do.
You know, there -- a lot of --
people say, "Well, aren't
campaigns hard?"
and all those things.
And there are some
very hard moments.
But doing "SNL"
was a fun moment.
And as you know,
my husband did it several times.
And I was just grateful
to be a part of that.
I had a great time. It was fun
-Another thing that bonded
your family with the Bidens is
and you mentioned it earlier
military service.
You know, obviously it's bee
true of both your families
Is that something that Joh
and Joe would speak about often?
-Often, yes.
You know, we --
our sons both left
at about the same time for Iraq.
And so, here, Joe was runnin
for vice president,
my husband
was running for president,
and we both had two sons serving
in Iraq at the same time.
You know, it's not only
a bonding experience
for the families,
but it made both families --
ours, and of course
the Biden family,
understand what the families
of troops
go through when they deploy.
I mean, it's hard.
And so I -- so he has
a different perspective
and a good perspective
on what it means
to serve your country
in the military
and the effect
it has on families.
But more importantly,
you know, we have that --
that commonality,
but as you know,
we have the commonality
of glioblastoma,
which hit both of our families
And so it would be hard
to separate the Biden and McCain
family in years to come
because we're just
too good of friends.
-You also have spoken of forme
Vice President Biden's empathy
And I guess that was on display.
He did come and visit your
husband in the final days, yeah?
-He did. He came out.
My husband was still alert
a little bit --
he wasn't too alert,
but he was alert and awake
and recognized Joe
and could talk a little bit.
And Joe had just been
through this with Beau.
I mean, he'd just been
through it.
And here he is, out in Arizona
Number one,
joking like crazy with John.
John was laughing
as best he could.
I mean, it was fun to watc
and just the normal things
We prayed together.
And then he consoled our family.
And I don't know that I coul
have had the strength,
having lost a son,
to have gone into
and helped another family
with the same problem
that we had.
So it it's an incredible -
I mean, we do have a lot
in common, and Joe --
This is a perfect example
of how Joe gives.
He just always gives, and he
cares so much about people
-Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to have this conversation.
-Thank you.
-Always lovely to see you.
Love to you and your family.
-Thank you very much.
Same to you.